j'espère que vous le savez muriel robin
on ne bouge pas c'est même répété à la
maison ah bon avec sa soul et on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle n'en est
rien
c'est mardi view google
la rébellion bien ficelé mater laissez
moi faire les efforts si à la fin il ne
fait pas le gage qui sera écrit la stran
couilles molles hockey muriel vous
pensez à quoi la cha ouais vous pensez à
quoi
à rien souvent je pense rien - allez
c'est d'être agréable bouddhiste sens et
je crois est naturellement mais parfois
gros comme utile petit vous lui
ressemblez actifs je voulais être jésus
d'avant fasse chanter que l'été ça ça
qu'on m'avait envoyé pour sauver le
monde après ils sont juste un peu trop
de boulot donc donc de jésus j'ai dû
passer annie girardot si oui tout ça ou
je lis même très à part ça qu'est ce qui
vous énerve le plus chez vous en vous
non c'est mais énervement je crois que
ça va mieux beaucoup mieux que ce qui
vous énerve le plus chez moi
nantes est parfois quand vous soyez j'ai
pas les foules dans les yeux avec je me
dis sourit vraiment ils sourient pas si
quand j'ai pas quand ça marche c'est le
j'adore
je suis d'avis de file des marchés
d'afrique c'est parce qu'il est méchant
ouais qu'est ce qui vous a fait le plus
mal comme insulte répond [ __ ] sa
j'adore
non c'est quand on me dit mais chante on
l'a dit souvent on me l'a écrit une fois
ça j'aime pas non méchant mais où se
cache du mariage avec le noir et à
quelqu'un qui m'a écrit qui a pensé qui
m'a insulté m'a dit que c'était très
méchant de chambre est celle de prendre
de l'argent faisait de l'argent sur le
dos des noirs bon quand on vous demande
d'autographe vous écrivez quoi alors ça
alors c'est très bizarre
j'écris mais robin c'était ça il n'y a
pas une gradation mettait pas amitié
qu'on sait vraiment si c'est sanglant
demande lâche 6 en france
sb j'ai peur je pensais qu est ce que
vous pourriez je suis beau rester 24
heures à vivre 24 heures 24 heures du
mans 24 heures moi je pense à rien je
ferais rien si peut-être j'irai chez
ikea je montrais un mode d'antan
monthermé
24 heures s'est assuré
quand est-ce que vous avez joué pour la
dernière fois mais pour quelle raison
parce que parce que le saviez vous venez
ici aujourd'hui parce que le film
sortait mais là ça a fait une sorte de
décompression voit la fatigue dernière
personne que vous ayez eu envie de tuer
j'ai pas envie de tuer s'est pas montrée
même pas quand même de temps en temps je
vais à la poste ou à sécu non j'aime pas
c'est que nous ne la faisons
j'en fais un truc voilà me tuer ou à
cause de la fina passe pas il faut
régler mais je sais vous que c'est trop
difficile
moi je voulais quitter le monde il ya la
finale perceval j'ai fait refaire votre
vie vous feriez quoi pas pareil ce
serait de la musique ça c'est sûr ah oui
c'est à ce point et jouer du piano quand
même à waimes rien enfin bon annoncé
avec la musique que ça vraiment y'a pas
guitare batterie joue devriez le faire
les déjà pensé au suicide oui oui salon
d'autrui les autres qui m'intéresse oui
pour d'auge à vis très bien aussi si
nous aiment un peu je te laisse de trois
lames de rasoir
tu regardes traité d' enfermer vraiment
est-ce que vous organisez rien d'inné où
on parle pas de vous oui si j'y suis
ban
marie d'abandon
maryline de mehdi charef